[Music]
so uh we're we're in the clench and
we're going to work with the uh
initiating
the uh arm drag
okay so we'll start uh you can either
grab this way you can grab this way you
can do a two on one you have that
mix it up okay but uh when you get it I
want you this time to go in front like
this so that your head's in front Okay
normally we're in the back this time
we're in front Okay and then you'll
catch and drive to lift that leg up
okay so again one two
front boom drive with your head leg will
come
up this way boom not in the back this
time and fr dry leg
come or two on one p on front drive leg
comes
up
okay one two when I'm here like this
I'm going to
turn
okay go one
two then into
the
angle this way
so I I can't go in and drag that's a y y
Clash but even on the first progression
when I came back now that's a y y CL do
you see that a lot of people when you
grab he's going to try pull back and
that's when you do the Dr do you
understand on this one now we're taking
that basic and coming off the line here
going so his energy is going this way
and I hit it at the 90
okay so my
foot goes here in
my head stays in the front boom when I
hit it
here okay there's not there's not two
there's not two ARS right so if if I if
I grab here I'm not just grabbing your
arm and I'm not just pulling your
shoulder right I'm grabbing your center
right I'm I'm here like this I'm moving
I got your Center so what I want you to
move I don't want you to leave your feet
there and pull your pull your shoulders
Mo your head because that's the leg I
want okay you see that so if I if I'm
here right I'm going to move that whole
leg towards me that whole leg comes back
to towards
me it doesn't matter which which
technique I'm doing I don't want to pin
your feet by pulling your shoulder I
have to move your body forward on the
turn I move your body forward cuz that's
what puts the leg there okay okay so you
connect let's say you're you're more
there I grab okay then I move the center
in that's what brought the leg there and
already you see my hand is
waiting
boom boom it's already waiting okay and
remember pulse on the back of the knee
so the arm wraps around don't use your
finger strength
okay so move the
center Center leg waiting try catch and
we're going to bring it up more to Here
Come Over the
[Music]
Top boom boom boom up high under your
armpit okay and this leg over the top
this arm
top again try to make it feel like
nothing
okay couple of details here come
around we shouldn't see his foot come
off the ground before his shoulders go
back be be a man and
don't not it's not going to happen okay
it's not it's not ju-jitsu either so one
take the flank
angle when you take the flank angle you
see
you
like got it you have to just like in the
CL drills you have to feel if you have
the tension or if you don't and if you
feel tension it's not right you got to
release the tension so in these drills
here as you go you have to feel if you
using muscle you should not feel muscle
should not feel muscle at all so look
over
here you see that that Ro I'm picking it
up you're going to shove that leg down
with musle you see so I have to go all
the way around on the other side you see
that so I have
leverage and I can grab and keep you
moving so that leg never gets
heavy got
it so I put it together I move him it's
up high high high high all the way
around and keep him moving try to pull
down he can't because he's moving got it
okay don't feel your muscles you feel
your muscles while you might feel strong
you actually weak a couple places where
you find this is he goes to grab you you
see he goes to grab you and there's your
there it is right
there so he's got like a reverse K and
it's the same thing find his Center move
it right move it and there it is or he
goes for a clinch okay he goes for that
clinch and I'm out there's the two on
one right there and you pass Mo it okay
got it so either he this time UK is
going to grab you I I don't care which
one and you find
it or they get in they get past maybe
he's maybe I'll be the okay so uh I I
got it you got to find your way out
there is right there you see and there
it is right okay on the
UK
got same technique more dyamic okay all
right okay what's wrong with that I
didn't drag him no it's so basic it's
such a iido up what is it was her
ton in front of him no see it's like
it's so I can't see it I'm a fish in the
water and I can't see it okay so what am
I doing here waiting waiting okay so I'm
moving moving he's got to
work do you understand hi okay don't
we're not doing that we started that way
with the basic technique right why do we
start that way
okay yes to simplify the field right
make it a cultivation field but now
we're starting to get a little more
Dynamic now there you're not going to
get so if I if I if you're there
and I got that hold you're not you're
not freaking counter nothing you see
that if he if he moves and I barely you
see I barely got it and then he's going
to be out of it you understand okay here
we go
[Music]
drive drive drive